so before I get started I'd like to
share a story
now a year ago I started on the biggest
project of my career
this was basically a huge refactor that
we were doing and the goal was to
eventually have a better architecture
better user experience latencies Etc
I never worked on a project of this
scale before
um and so there were multiple teams
involved multiple stakeholders and I was
very excited
again there were multiple teams involved
but it was my team that was that was at
the heart of it
um I was obviously I was understandably
very nervous but I was very excited
because I was going to be working
directly with two technical leads
now the start the project started off
like fairly uh fairly simple the first
couple of months were pretty
straightforward but things got
interesting around the mid-year Mark
which is when three of the five
Engineers who were working on this left
you can imagine that this was not at all
a part of the plan never in my wireless
imagination had I accounted for this
when the three Engineers left we were
about 60 done with the project but the
remaining 40 was the really tricky part
because this was when everything was
going to start sort of coming together
we were going to slowly start rolling
out the changes see how metrics were
being impacted
now obviously there was a huge vacuum
that was created when these Engineers
left and they were just the two of us
remaining
um but I was the only team member who
sort of worked on this project
throughout so I was then made the
project lead you can imagine my
excitement
um because of the circumstances I like
to call myself an accidental Project
Lead
but anyway we still had work to do this
was around eight months ago and since
then it's been such a tug of war getting
this project to the Finish Line I really
thought we couldn't do it the story does
have a happy ending though because we
officially wrapped up the project just
last week even though it was quite
delayed which is understandable given
the circumstances but what does this
story have to do with why I'm here today
I've been doing a lot of reflection in
the past couple of months and there's
some key learnings that I wanted to
share in the aftermath of this
experience
the first thing that I want to talk
about is ambiguity which was one of the
first things that I also experienced as
I worked on this project
now when you start out in your career
the work is mostly handed to you right
your likely handed tickets which means
that what gets to you is a small
achievable and deliverable subtask
all or most of the ambiguity has been
removed from it because it's likely
undergone multiple iterations as part of
like the project development cycle
now something that I experienced is that
as you become more senior the amount of
ambiguity that you're going to be
dealing with is going to start
increasing as well and that's because as
you're as you're moving up the seniority
you're becoming a part of the very
initial stages of the project
think of the project in terms of a
timeline with the start and end denoted
by exit conception and execution
respectively now what I mean by
conception is that you're basically
identifying technical Endeavors that you
feel your team or company should
undertake
as you become senior you start moving
from the execution end and more towards
the conception end you're likely going
to be overseeing multiple Services
multiple projects and as your scope
increases so does the amount of
ambiguity that you're going to be
dealing with
actively embracing ambiguity is an
inevitable part of being an engineer
this is also where your understanding of
the project will come in handy the
clearer your comprehension is of the
what and why the easier it will be for
you to translate that ambiguity into the
how with clear and actionable items
to understand the what and why you need
to understand the project inside it out
and its value to the business the better
you understand it the better you'll be
able to Define what needs to be done a
big part of your understanding is also
realizing the value that you bring to
the business how is this initiative
contributing to the overall goals of the
company is the focus on accuracy or
latency or both how can Revenue be
potentially impacted
as an engineer you always think about
your project from a technical
perspective right you think about the
right way to implement a feature you
think about design patterns you think
about latencies you think about testing
the happy path versus the not so happy
paths among other things
but as an engineer have you ever thought
about Revenue have you ever thought
about how a faulty change could lead to
a degraded user experience which would
inevitably be detrimental to your
business's Revenue
as you get to work on more high-stakes
projects and as you gain more visibility
in your role your mistakes could start
becoming more costly the point of this
discussion is not to scare you from
making mistakes because that's an
inevitable part of your growth as an
engineer the point is is that you need
to be cognizant of the cost of that
mistake so that you can learn to
mitigate the risk accordingly
think about it this way an inexperienced
engineer will deploy an experiment at
any time of the day without thinking
about traffic patterns or without
thinking about how they could
potentially mitigate the risk if their
change is faulty an experienced engineer
on the other hand will know not to
deploy right before a long weekend or
during high traffic times or when there
is an ongoing outage because they know
that the impact to potential Revenue
could be significantly larger
now do you remember when I said that
this project was really delayed yeah
that was a pretty awkward position for
me to begin you can imagine that as a
Project Lead there was there were tons
of questions being directed uh towards
me so how did I navigate that time
period the trick was communication
just like we're taught to ask clarifying
questions when we're presented a
technical uh like problem within an
interview do the same for your project
work as well
I remember working on this one task
um and I completed it in three days I
was very happy with myself I presented
it to my technical lead and I was told
straight up that this is completely
incorrect because I completed that task
based on an assumption that I had made
that's three days of development work
wasted and a further X number of days
that it took me to redo the entire thing
secondly be transparent and proactive
while can Wing blockers and expected
delays and there's going to be a lot of
blockers and a lot of delays
escalating issues on time can get you
the help you may not even realize you
need
I also learned to adjust the level of
detail it is that I'm expected to share
based on the audience which is extremely
important especially when you're working
on projects of that involve multiple
teams or stakeholders you're likely
going to be interacting with people from
other teams Engineers on your team
Engineers from other teams project
managers technical leads and not
everyone would necessarily require the
same amount of detail right if I'm
talking to an immediate team member they
probably need a deep they would probably
need a deeper deeper technical dive but
if say I'm talking to a project manager
they might just be okay having uh like a
more more of a bird's eye view of the
what the current state of the project is
moving on politely ask people to repeat
themselves if you're unsure especially
in meetings a lot of the times most
people are wondering the same thing but
because of diffusion of responsibility
no one ends up asking those questions
similarly if it was a very long meeting
and a lot of things were discussed or
discussed take meaning take meeting
minutes uh summarize what was discussed
at the very end just quickly review what
the follow-up items are and what action
items are assigned to what team members
lastly I also want to talk about the
importance of documentation which is
something that most Engineers generally
dread doing
um now when you're actively working on a
project it's very easy to recall
commonly used commands that you use for
testing or debugging your code right
like especially if you're executing
those commands to the terminal you can
just very easily access your most
commonly used commands this is okay as
long as you're actively working on the
project but say you go on an extended
vacation or you finish the project but a
couple of months later you have to come
back and do a minor fix accessing those
commands is not going to be as easy this
time I'm guilty of this myself there's
been so many times where I've had to
like sift through slack conversations
trying to find the command that I need
documentation as you go along can save
you potential headaches later on
now another lesson that I learned
particularly because of the three
Engineers that left was that project
planning is complex and nothing is set
in stone you have to account for
surprises like these in your project
timelines so account for vacation days
last minute time offs civic holidays
people resigning or any other urgent
tasks that might come up
your timelines aren't meant to be
perfect and that's okay but it's
important to be realistic about them
now going back to my story when the two
technical leads left
um and I was made the Project Lead I was
expected to share a new uh project
completion date right now I've never
done this before so using whatever
little context I had and what my current
understanding of the state of the
project was I shared a new completion
date for the end of November
this was hilariously over optimistic
um because I completely forgotten to
account for holidays Thanksgiving in the
US happens around like the late November
time and that's because it's so close to
Christmas season a lot of people save
their vacation days for that same time
as well I'd completely forgotten to
account for that luckily this mistake
wasn't too costly for me because I later
found out that my manager had added a
little buffer time to this November end
deadline and the and the completion date
that had been shared with stakeholders
was for after New Year's
needless to say I was very grateful for
to my manager for having my back
to summarize the complexities and
unpredictability of project planning I
would just like to remind you of
Murphy's Law anything that can go wrong
will go wrong the eternal optimist in me
has begrudgingly accepted this and I
think you should acknowledge it as well
as inconvenient as that is I do think
that it makes you a better project
planner because you'll know to add
buffers in your timelines and you'll
have contingency plans in case something
goes awry
just a couple of weeks ago I had this
experiment that I was ready to turn on I
was very excited everything was all set
I tested it and I was basically going to
turn it on it was going to run overnight
and then the next day I would have data
ready
um so I mentioned this in like a team
check-in meeting that we had and my
manager just casually reminded me that
in case there is an ongoing outage just
don't turn on the experiment I agreed
but internally I was like there's
nothing that's gonna go wrong I've
tested it there's minimal risk I'm just
like I'm just collecting logs so like
what can go wrong it sounded like a
perfect plan to me
as soon as I was about to turn on the
experiment I was alerted of an ongoing
outage because I uh because of which I
could not turn on the experiment
um there is like my perfect plan was out
the window there's there's no such thing
now as a project lead you can also
imagine that there was uh more to my day
than just coding and that happens to be
the case for most Engineers you're
attending meetings you're updating
documentation you're doing code reviews
you're applying to emails and messages
and yeah you happen to code as well now
if you think back to your operating
systems classes this is exactly what
context switching is and this is very
detrimental to developer productivity
now I worked long enough to in Tech to
realize that it's unrealistic to expect
that there's not going to be any context
switching in your day but you can
definitely reduce the amount that you do
this includes things like time blocking
and time batching which basically means
that you block off times where you can
do focus on interrupted or deep work
even if those are just 30 minute chunks
during your day
I'm also a big fan of prioritized to-do
list something that I really like to do
on Sundays which is when I start feeling
a sense of impending doom is to dump
everything that I need to do for for the
week onto my to-do list
Um this can include very trivial things
as well such as like making payments or
getting groceries or whatnot the next
thing that I do is that I categorize
categorize these according to like work
school and like miscellaneous items but
the most important aspect of this entire
activity is to assign a priority to each
item that I need to do Mondays can be
overwhelming for a lot of people but
having this prioritized to-do list helps
me feel more in control because I have
an exact plan of attack for for my week
making difficult decisions is part of
any leadership position and a Project
Lead was no different the most
noteworthy decision that I remember
debating was the question of taking on
Tech debt
this is the Eternal question of getting
it done versus doing it right you want
to finish the project on time but you
also want to roll it out with minimum
defects and those two things you usually
do not go hand in hand
when I first started out as an engineer
I had a very idealistic view on Tech
that I even remember expressing that
opinion very strongly in an interview
and needless to say I did get the job
debt in general carries a very negative
connotation right so I assume the same
held true for Tech debt as well
Tech that is basically the cost of
getting it done as opposed to doing it
right it includes things like a
last-minute hockey fix poor or a
complete lack of documentation
altogether or a poor testing Suite among
other things
similar to context switching I think
it's unrealistic to expect not to have
any Tech debt there's definitely
circumstances where it will be it you
have to take that texted on but
simultaneously you need to be cognizant
to pay it off in a timely manner
accumulating Tech that can lead to a
Slowdown in development work or Worse
having to rewrite the entire application
but if there's no alternative to taking
on Tech debt how do you alleviate the
situation by remembering to pay it off
but there's more to it than that
don't treat working on techdead as a
second class citizen encourage a culture
within your team where paying it off is
celebrated that's actually a custom that
we have within our team so if any
engineer pays off any Tech debt we
remember to give them like a shout out
during our weekly team meetings
don't play the blame game if you have
taken on Tech debt own up to it
I would also suggest quantifying it I
think in general we understand numbers
better right so if you if you're able to
quantify the cost of that Tech debt I
think it's very easy it becomes a bit
easier to sort of assign a priority to
to that Tech that for example if a lack
of a testing Suite resulted in a
degraded user experience you can
quantify that using the loss in revenue
and it'll immediately assign a priority
to that Tech data lastly share your
knowledge if you've paid off Tech debt
and you've noticed consistent themes in
detected that your team tends to take on
share those themes so uh to prevent
future occurrences of of the same issue
so to quickly recap
um the lessons that the the lessons that
I shared include embracing the ambiguity
but to do that you need to understand
your project inside and out and its
value to the business
next practice clear effective and
efficient communication acknowledge that
project planning is complex and that
nothing is set in stone acknowledge that
context switching is an unfortunate but
inevitable part of your role and lastly
realize that technical debt might be a
necessary evil
this brings me to the end of my session
if if you have any feedback or if you
want to share your learnings from back
when you were a junior engineer I would
love to hear them please feel free to
reach out either by LinkedIn or by email
and yeah thank you for attending my
session today
[Applause]